[Musique]
à 19 ans Enzo benmegal compte deux
sélections avec l'équipe de France moins
de 20 ans une première apparition sous
le maillot bleu face à l'Italie lors du
tournoi des 6 nations 2023 un souvenir
gravé à jamais dans sa mémoire
qui marque parce que c'est quelque chose
qui représente vraiment notre pays c'est
vraiment l'identité de la France et puis
après le match en Italie c'est juste
énorme en plus on avait des supporters
puis faire des matchs sur des stades où
il y a beaucoup de monde c'est ça donne
toujours envie c'est toujours des bons
moments qu'on passe là depuis qu'on est
petit le but c'est d'aller le plus loin
possible de jouer en pro de faire des
sélections un maximum du coup c'est un
peu le début d'un rêve qui se réalise
talentueux s'exprime à travers sa
vitesse et ses appuis des qualités
physiques qu'il met au service du
collectif c'est un incroyable joueur
finisseur rapide
qui désormais c'est-à-dire qu'il va se
proposer un peu partout sur le terrain
et cet esprit d'initiative
nous intéresse donc voilà pourquoi enzo
est parmi nous Enzo ben méga a commencé
le rugby en mini poussin à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines son premier
club c'est le skyrugby et la suivi ses
deux grands frères Mathis et Alix c'est
mon plus grand frère donc Mathis qui a
commencé en faire puis ça a été suivi
par mon autre frère et je suis allé par
automatisme ça s'est bien passé donc
j'ai continué et dans la catégorie moins
de 14 ans il rejoint le Racing 92 le
plus jeune de la fratrie fera ses gammes
dans le club des Hauts-de-Seine des
Minimes jusqu'aux espoirs pour jouer ces
deux premiers matchs de Top 14 en
septembre 2022 franchement le début de
saison c'était une grande surprise et
vraiment que du plaisir je m'y attendais
pas du tout et de faire les deux
premiers matchs de Top 14 des titulaires
et de voir tout ce qui tout ce qui a eu
autour c'était juste magique le but
final c'est la Coupe du monde après pour
le prix faut passer par par le 6 nations
faire des bonnes performances que ça
soit en sélection en club et puis après
on espère que si tout se passe bien la
Coupe du Monde sera sur le chemin le
championnat du monde des moins de 20 ans
aura lieu du 24 juin au 14 juillet en
Afrique du Sud et du 15 au 30 juillet au
Kenya
[Musique]